and I was reading this other book while
back as well which was written by the
guy who ran the human genome project and
I don't remember exactly what it was
called but it was something like a
scientists case for God is something
like that and one of the things he
referred to which didn't strike me as
hard as it should have to begin with was
the he thought that one of the phenomena
say that justified a belief in a
transcendent being was something like
the moral intuition of human beings that
you know we have a sense of right and
wrong and you know it's certainly in
what happens in Genesis and the story of
Adam and Eve is that that that story
announces the coming of the sense of
right and wrong right the knowledge of
good and evil and it isn't something we
ascribe to animals it's something that's
unique to human beings animals can be
predators and you know and they can be
gentle and you can have a relationship
with them but you never think of an evil
cat or you know or an evil wolf even
though they're you know they're
predatory about human beings we have
this capacity to judge between good and
evil right and wrong and it's really an
integral part of our being and I think
you can make an evolutionary case for
that a biological case for that as you
can make a biological case for most of
what is relevant about human beings
because we're biological creatures but
we don't really understand the
significance of that like what happens
in the story of Adam and Eve is that
that's that realization not coming to
the knowledge of good and evil is
actually represented as a shift of
cosmic significance right it puts a it
puts a permanent fracture in the
structure of being and you know if you
think of human beings as insignificant
ants on a tiny dust mote in the middle
of an infinite cosmos cosmos that cares
less for us then who cares fundamentally
if human beings have the knowledge to
distinguish between good and evil but if
you give consciousness a central role in
being and you can make a perfectly
reasonable case for that because without
consciousness there's no being as far as
anyone can determine so it may be much
more central than we think and
and I really don't think there's a
counter-argument to that like not a
solid one you can state that
consciousness is epiphenomena land and
that the world is fundamentally
materialistic and it doesn't matter that
there's consciousness you can state that
but you can make an equally credible
case the other way and certainly our
lived experience is that consciousness
is crucial obviously and we treat each
other as if most of the time we're
valuable conscious beings and we
wouldn't give up our consciousness even
though it's often consciousness of
suffering and so then I think another
problem with the book is that it's it's
sort of predicated on the idea that life
is for happiness and I don't think
that's right and I don't think that's
how people experience life and I might
be wrong but it seems to me that people
experience life as something like a
series of crucial ethical decisions it's
something like that I mean when I just
can't imagine and maybe I'm being naive
about this but I can't imagine that I
can't imagine another being
that's like mean in in most senses that
isn't constantly wrestling in some sense
with what the next proper thing to do is
it's not like it's obvious it's not
bloody obvious and it doesn't mean
you'll do the right thing because you
don't law lots of times and you know
that by your own judgement right because
you're making mistakes all the time
sometimes you don't know what you're
doing and maybe it's a mistake and maybe
it isn't and who's to say but that isn't
what I'm talking and what I'm talking
about when you know that what you're
doing is wrong and you go ahead and do
it anyways people do that all the time
and that's also extremely peculiar you
bloody well think that if you knew it
was wrong and you told yourself that it
was wrong that that would be sufficient
so that you just wouldn't do it but that
isn't what you're like at all you know
and you can tell yourself something is
wrong a 50 times and you'll do it the
51st time and then you'll feel you know
like like you deserve to feel probably
and but it doesn't stop you and so so
then I think the other problem with the
viewpoint the idea that the suffering of
life eradicate sits utility is that it's
predicated on the idea that happiness or
lack of suffering even is
the right criteria by which to judge
life and I don't think that's how we
actually experience life I think what we
do instead is put ourselves through a
series of excruciating moral choices you
know and one of the things that that's
really significant about the biblical
stories and I think about the the entire
implicit philosophy you know that's
embedded in the stories is that that's
how life is presented in in the stories
is all of these individuals first
they're individuals - not groups and
second they're agonizing over their
moral choices all the time all the time
and they have a relationship with God
and but it's not a it's not a directive
relationship exactly even the people to
whom God speaks directly which I suspect
is not something you'd exactly want to
have happen is it's there's still even
the fact that they have a direct
relationship with God doesn't stop them
from being tormented continually by
their moral choices and so the world is
presented as a moral landscape not as a
not as a place that justifies itself by
happiness it's presented as a moral
landscape and people are presented as
creatures who traverse through the moral
landscape making ethical decisions that
determine the course of the world and
that seems to me to be right and that's
not a that's not the same as happiness
by any stretch of the imagination it's a
whole different category of being and
you know and then I thought that through
a lot and I think well we do make
choices and what we do is contend with
the future you know and that the future
seems to appear to us as a realm of
possibility that's a more accurate way
of thinking about it then then that the
future presents itself to it to us as a
realm of determined things it's its
presents itself as a realm of
possibility and there's good choices in
that realm and there's poor choices or
even evil choices in that realm and
we're negotiating continually deciding
which of those choices we're going to
bring into being that seems to me to be
from
logically indisputable and we certainly
treat each other as if that's what we're
doing because we hold each other
responsible for our actions you know
with some exceptions and that we're
deciding each moment whether to make
things better or worse and that seems to
me to be correct and I think that that's
what these stories illustrate they don't
say that directly you know although I
think it gets more and more explicit as
the narrative unfolds but and then part
of the realism of the stories is that
the people aren't the people that are
being presented are by no means good I
mean maybe with the exception of Noah
Noah seemed to be a pretty good guile
they did he did get drunk and you know
and and and end up naked exposed to his
sons and so forth and but I mean he
isn't talked about a lot as a character
it's a pretty compressed story but
Abraham I mean Abraham had plenty of
problems not least of which was in his
inability to leave home and then you
know his lying about his wife and their
there's all sorts of mistakes and then
Jacob who were gonna talk about tonight
is an even more morally ambivalent
character he's especially at the
beginning of the story he's it's he
isn't the sort of person that you would
pick out especially if you were a hack
writer
you wouldn't pick him out as the hero of
the story he does a lot of things that
are really pretty reprehensible and
takes him an awful long time to learn
better and yet he's the person who's put
forward as the father of the 12 tribes
of Israel it's from this flawed person
that the people that that maybe that
whose story you might say is that the
fundamental constitutes the fundamental
underpinning of our culture it's it's
from this deeply flawed individual that
that group emerges and so you might
think of that as a relief to because you
know you're no knight in shining armor
you know with with a with a pure moral
past I mean people make mistakes of
catastrophic proportions non-stop you
know
and that also means that these stories
put forward something approximating hope
because in their realism in their moral
realism they present heroes I suppose
the heroes of renown right the
patriarchs of old let's say who are
realistic people who have fits of anger
and rage and who are murderous at times
and who are deeply deeply embroiled with
family dispute and who who have
adulterous affairs and and like they do
all the terrible things that people do
and the weird thing is is that God is
still with them and you know it isn't
obvious what that means or even if it
means anything but it's very it's not
disputable as far as I can tell that a
were conscious and that consciousness is
a transcendent phenomena which which we
do not understand and that the landscape
that we traverse through is moral like
every story you ever watch anything that
grips your imagination on the screen or
in the theatre like any story that grabs
you is a story of moral striving it's
just not interesting otherwise right the
person has to be confronted with complex
moral choices and then you see the
outcome and you know the good guy does
it right and the bad guy does it badly
and things don't go so well for the bad
guy generally and if it's a bit more
sophisticated the good and the bad or in
the same individual and that's you know
that's a more compelling story but so we
could say well let's we could make the
assumption then it might be worthwhile
thinking of the world as a as it has
been thought of classically as a theater
upon which the forces of good and evil
continually strive for dominance and I
for the life of me especially after I
started reading deeply into 20th century
history and all the terrible things that
happened in the 20th century and all the
terrible unbelievably incomprehensible
things that people did to one another I
just couldn't see seeing things any
other way is realistic you know because
I don't think that you can immerse
yourself in 20th century history without
coming to the conclusion that evil is a
reality and if it's a reality that it
depends on what you mean by reality but
it's fundamental enough reality for me
and if it's reality then I don't see how
you can escape from the conclusion that
the cosmos as we experience it at least
is a place of moral striving and well
that's one of the things that's really
illustrated in the story of Jacob and
and I found that quite striking